son muchos temas muy variados por
ejemplo la energía Arabia Saudita quiere
transformarse en un país productor de
energía solar también la seguridad y la
defensa la situación en medio oriente
recordemos que hay un acercamiento entre
Irán y Arabia Saudita Francia quiere
saber cómo eso Por ejemplo puede afectar
al Líbano como decías tú también él
viene y por una larga visita ya que la
próxima semana jueves y viernes va a
participar de esa Cumbre por el nuevo
pacto financiero que es una iniciativa
francesa y también el lunes que viene va
a participar en la reunión del comité
que decide los países que acogen las
exposiciones universales el recordemos
que es el gobernador de facto del reino
petrolero y por lo tanto quiere hacer de
su país una de las diez potencias del
mundo de aquí al año 2030 tiene muchos
proyectos megalómanos y uno justamente
de ellos es que acoja la exposición
universal en el año 2030 pero lo más
importante es que el presidente Manuel
macron como decías quiere atraer a los
países no han Lidia y el tercer mundo
para que apoyen a Ucrania en el
conflicto con Rusia y la situación no
puede ser mejor ya que Arabia Saudita se
encuentra en una situación muy tensa
como Q en el seno de la OPEP recordemos
que Arabia Saudita para poder hacer
todos esos proyectos necesita un barril
muy caro un barril de petróleo con un
peso muy alto sin embargo justamente
Rusia está en la otra postura necesita
vender petróleo para financiar la guerra
y por lo tanto necesita un barril bajo y
ahí hay un gran problema recordemos que
el príncipe invitó incluso al presidente
a la última reunión de los Países Árabes
Hola Erika Esta es una visita que
despierta también la oposición de las
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos en
que se centran especialmente estas
críticas hacia Arabia Saudita
sí recordemos que estas críticas ya se
repitieron hace un año cuando se
reunieron el príncipe y el presidente
Emmanuel macron primero porque Estados
Unidos y los servicios de inteligencia
de ese país han dicho siempre que es él
quien está detrás del asesinato de jamal
caso y el periodista Saudita que fue
encontrado muerto en el consulado de
Arabia saudí en Estambul y por lo tanto
las ong Siempre han pedido que no lo
reciba que no haya esta real política
del presidente Manuel macron interesado
en el petróleo más que la defensa de los
Derechos Humanos que son los valores de
Francia y ahora también amnistía
internacional enviado un mail una carta
pidiendo que el presidente Manuel macron
defienda a Siete jóvenes que van a ser
condenados a muerte o que están
condenados que van a ser ejecutados en
Arabia Saudita por hechos que cometieron
cuando eran a menores han pedido que el
presidente interceda ante el príncipe
para evitar esa declaración y también
para que eso sea el comienzo quizás de
La abolición de la pena de muerte en el
reino